not that corner we advocate to use don't
upload a alright you're gonna need a
librarian like some Japanese infomercial
hi I'm Alex and I'm RIA and I've
participated in a lot of challenges for
tasty so today I thought I'd ask my
friend Rea to teach me one of her
favorite Japanese recipes but with a
twist
hi Alex lucky on on yachts go to Kalani
motion ma Santoshi Mata seonyeong goda
schedule Yoshioka predict myself
are you ready I took Japanese one a week
in middle school
okay so I think I know what I'm doing do
you when I shall fear Japanese domo
arigato mr. Roboto
it sounds like gumball so you may
suddenly had a huge lifestyle change and
you eat more healthy way to yeah so I
try I think this is the best you will
love it oh yeah so I know it's healthy
then I don't say see but it's fit see
our lifestyle okay
should I just put them all together all
right come on gumball come on oh yes
jam mother sighs Shaunie oh c'mon
and imma did you tell me to do something
oka Mayo and I must thank you so much so
sweet of you to say Oh commit okay okay
okay okay
rice knee kappa kappa look at me any
company couple do you know how to count
japanese Oh
et me to need son cheat oh go
Hyrum know you know up to you you know
yeah look know
gggg need two cups of rice not hugging
their each each sheet little excited
that I know how to count it down there I
know I like my water move it around wish
it around wash it wash it oh yeah oh
yeah meesa I'm assuming it's water
high-knee cup two cups yes
there are cows Emmitt that may alter
Chema's jutsu you know Stephanie Hamas a
blogger a blogger
Avril Doggett Donna disco I get that I'm
assuming you open this so interesting
I've never used a pillow so so so how do
you had this before
he see it's tofu bites fried fried tofu
okay I mean I thought fried tofu before
I guess ha ha she there she they call a
palapa roll it
yeah that's good it's askin mmm throw it
out give it a little massage a little
tofu massage good nothing whatever I
don't got to you know I thought they
could Olga a kiosk anonymous daijoubu
stop no then another one mmm go over
flattening it out I don't know maybe I
need to make a little sandwich
have you been to Japan yeah I have I was
like 12 or something so I don't really
fully appreciate mmm like I need to go
back for sure
but I loved it it was so cool so fun so
beautiful do you remember why you eh
I remember having like the freshest cut
a lobster in front of us but yeah I want
to go back and feed the little deer the
kill deer
we're gonna do that together I'm already
planning the trip hi job Humber
Nicodemus hamburger took them up there
took them up there in a triangle channel
okay I can do that
all right Oh means it book Donnie pocket
it means you cop to me they'll walk past
you must water in the pot water in the
pot amazingly a mess I water in the back
then
okay I'm assuming we're boiling the
water yes
oh but I'll get a blanket oh boy didn't
we boil the tofu okay okay seems a
little weird in there little how long we
I eat but one minute yes okay I know
that was gonna be like some other number
18 I don't know this is the fried so I
want to remove some of the fattiness oh
well you know to like make it healthier
it's a little too greasy for you done
dude
yeah I noticed cuz the grease kind of
came up on the chopstick when I was
rolling it out has it been a minute done
and into the strainer just dump it hai
hai da means it needs ooh I always
forget this one you say it a million
times
music water yes yes it's like miss you
miss you water gonna try to like
remember these things you just want to
cool it down
cool okay I joke she bought him us put
in there mmm-hmm no she bought it
squeeze it I was doing it because it won
yes that's good gentle gentle and
because it's a anytime just do a little
gentle squeeze
how does they feel kind of cool yes good
gentle I'm not the most gentle
[Laughter]
lo siento lo siento means I'm sorry how
do I say oh magnified hi hi yo Kenickie
my stop can I have a towel yeah Sugino
step a barangay
Oh tofu hmm you don't get that unfolded
mmm yeah yeah mom all right
just open them hmm all of them hi one
day for you have had this dish I don't
think I have I have no idea some sort of
tofu rice maybe sounds good I'm getting
hungry means at all eat a cup one cup of
water high in there oh oh oh oh god you
sound nice on three mmm
sesame seed sugar high ha ha
three teaspoons three tablespoons hey
what is this sugar yeah Japanese okay
three in there we got it
Ichi two three mmm show you show you
I know show you oh yes so I put soy
sauce high sound in here I eat
meeting new high okay
what hey big loves Emma stir it up
hey should like dissolve the sugar it's
all I am so so so smart just so they all
you didn't want in there whoo-hoo doll
sauce it then heat it up don't hate it
bubbling bubble boy oh boy no bring it
to a boil simmer so this otoshi without
scooty muss then we're gonna do cover it
yeah
with a paper cover with paper then wool
oh then we put it on here check out oh
no put the paper on top mmm cut it the
paper so so Saturday fern put it on top
then put a come on no no come just put
the baby so cut the cake burn the circle
oh good what a Oh Oh Connie this is
Riyaz origami like stuff I always forgot
it but it's a trick to cut the paper in
a perfect circle Oil Co Co Co Co Co yeah
I know half were for ha ha ha
yeah Co Co Co Co Co keep also like
what's out a little steamy
I wonder how many times you'd need to do
this to actually learn Japanese I feel
like I'm getting somewhere good just
make noises that's how you get for the
reason we do this we don't have a load
of like Sea Maringa likud it's kind of
like a lid about with steam
I saw someone do this for like making
steamed buns okay
yes in Japan we have smaller lid for
days called otoshi buta but this is
French technique called cartouche
shewket oohs all right so how long do we
got this one for Japan I think that's
above what I know
no okay geppu I know she left another
mother it'll be
it'll be evaporated then take the paper
out then we take it off you need Reena
move it like this right now right yeah
it will evaporate me okay in the word
vomit I just did
I'll let you just say hi what are we
ready to go hi
I feel like I kind of know what's going
on now I don't know what it is cuz I've
never had this yeah but we have like
some rice we got like a syrupy tofu kind
of thing I love it so let's go team us
fat bowl corsage uni hot take off the
thing salt no sugar no it's tricky
because salt Oh sounds like soaked but
it's sugar
haha G a teaspoon Oh one teaspoon me jus
T so it's neat hi dad Filipe
she'll salt oh she does she
yes you they should be switched why
because she like sugar salt Oh son oh
sorry humba humba humba hi
oh sorry me hide something over here
rice vinegar yeah okay me too fuzzy me
yeah
each mother mas okay - mother go ha Oh
kneecap booger I know I put a little in
here cut over much hmm put this in it no
oh we're not Karuma Oh what have we not
used this okay all fuzzy right mm-hmm
what's beautiful it's a cushy I think
hi why I'm gonna paste that oh we get to
taste good oh yeah hi Oh II see
oh she oh I know it's good boy she means
delicious
oh she does so yummy
you keep my sofa sorry one receptor
gumball bowel put him off take the
finger mm-hmm
what a wall crown drain it out back hi
hi so they did I don't okay
duh pay me I'm gonna dip my hand in
there okay just hmm Robin what am i
doing are we making with a little ball
so far is this like what they ate in
spirited away do they hate the little
triangle thing oh my I always wanted to
eat one of those so god Monica little
ball mm-hmm little round mm-hmm ah he
right then inside mmm open hmm in here
hi put it in there
so so so
so the reason you dip with saucy it's
like rice doesn't stick with them oh
yeah and also seasoning I get it yeah
got it cool haha okay this is no day to
spirit away but I'm excited either oh
yeah hey Tony giddy oh that's only good
yeah but this looks great little tofu
hat on the rice what's it called
you naughty the Sheikh Inari sushi yeah
so it's type of sushi hey does she pick
this for you sushi thank you so much
shall we done with the Japanese I did I
pass the test
yeah he was worried to be honest but I
also confident cuz you know how to cook
you know how's it good I think you did
great okay so let me bring my and we can
compare yeah yeah I might like a little
Messier I use exact the same amount but
you know - because I was eating us so
let's try original first your zoom
mm-hmm very well-seasoned hmm like I
think that's what makes it you know it's
like saucier yeah it's like very juicy I
mean yeah the tofu like soaks up the
juice juicy juicy all right sure jawline
mm-hmm oh I could eat like ten of these
yeah it's good right yeah it's like snot
cheers Cheers
did you eat these after school sometimes
so yeah really yeah I love it
if I do say so myself I didn't think I
could do it me too
I knew you could do it but you followed
exactly what I you know I didn't know
pretty much yeah look the same tastes
the same both juicy juicy yeah I think
you did great thank you how to give you
five hundred million points
Wow if you make this energy do she
tagged me on instagram tag Alex how are
you yeah yeah I hope you guys enjoyed
and see you next time juicy juicy oh yes
[Music]
you